ready and action
hey everybody its charlie happy
comic-con week we got a whole bunch of
Flash stuff to talk about episode 1 we
know the title we know what's going down
and everybody's been asking why Barry is
wearing his season 1 costume what's
going on here because he's fighting this
flash villain with his daughter Nora
Allen who we see in her full very excess
looking costume so I'll explain why her
Flash symbol looks a little bit
different than the one in the comics
like there's a reason why their Flash
symbols look the way they do like they
look cool but they're also functional so
I'll explain what's going on with this
flash season 1 suit but if you're
finding me for the first time it's Comic
Con week be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
tend to that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so big
surprise the title of episode 1 is Nora
the title of episode 2 is blocked so
episode 1 is all about finishing that
conversation explaining what Nora was
about to tell everyone inside the house
at the end of the finale
bitchin I'm your daughter Nora from the
future and I think I made a big
big mistake
I think I made a big big mistake then
obviously she told them what the big
mistake was they'll be showing that to
us in Episode one remember TV is a show
not tell medium they need to visually
give that to us which is also related to
this flash season one soon so people
like why would Barry have the old suit
if he just got the new suit during
season four
well what probably happened is is this
is similar to what Nora did during the
course of season four have we met no no
I'm a complete and total stranger
I don't always pay no worse during the
finale she teams up with Barry to take
down the satellite implying that Barry
was not going to be strong enough to
take that down I don't think that he
would have died if Nora was born
otherwise there would have been this big
paradoxical loop where she came back to
save herself so that she could be born
and that's not really what her mistake
is about it's a bit broader than that
it's about the idea of her messing with
the past and trying to avoid some future
outcome but obviously she can't do it by
herself
and that's why she's come to get Barry's
help so there is a certain level of Nora
point going on we're gonna see a version
of that during episode one this flash
season one suit with Barry fighting this
villain here he looks like he's wearing
murmurs mask from the comics but the
murmurs that we saw in the TV show was a
little bit different so this might be a
different character that just looks like
comic book murmur at some point in the
past Nora probably came back to watch
Barry take down villains and this just
happens to be a moment in time that she
came to visit so was we're experiencing
it it's a moment from season one even
though it's a new scene that they're
shooting for the season five premiere
it's like new history that we didn't see
in between the other season one
adventures so it's not like Barry
suddenly destroyed his season four suit
or Nora has some crazy ability where she
can rewind time I know people had
questions about that after the finale
they'll explain exactly what her
abilities are in the first episode the
only real difference is in Nora's
speedster abilities and Barry's
speedster abilities are the color of her
lightning the TV show takes a lot of
liberties with the color of speedsters
lightning usually there's a more
fundamental reason why their lightning
is different colors the TV show does it
just so it's easy to
tell them apart when they're flying at
each other on screen they've kind of
gotten away from color as an indicator
of actual top speed after season 2 the
reason why they did the purple lightning
for iris was really just to set up this
Nora twist so that she had the two
different colors of lightning so if
you're wondering about lightning color
and speed they've kind of moved away
from that maybe they'll get back to it
in later seasons when we have more
speedster villains if we have more
speedster villains aside from that her
abilities aren't that different from
Barry's like she learned everything she
knows from her friends in the future
because team flash members are still
alive in the future some of them are
probably dead some of them are probably
villains like killer frost that's
probably why she didn't like her or
Harrison wells the only minor
differences that I'm expecting to see is
that she just has a different idea of
how to use her abilities that's usually
where you get into different speeds
durability --zz because the Speed Force
is sort of like this giant pool of
energy that they all pull from different
abilities are usually just a function of
the way that they come up with creative
uses of that energy like when Barry
vibrates his body faster than the human
eye can see so it seems like he's
invisible or when they legit phase
through stuff or throw lightning
[Music]
but just imagine that at some point in
the future Nora figured out how to use
her abilities to time-travel and then
because of all the crap that's going
down in the future she wanted to come
back to the past one to see her father
when he was still alive and do all these
awesome things that people talked about
you have to imagine that there are
legends of the flash in the future so
she came back to see that but also try
to fix what was wrong with the future so
you have to imagine she's already tried
something she made a big mistake
that's when she shows up on Barry's
doorstep so she's already tried to
change something in the past and created
her own version of Nora Point I've made
things worse holy crap she's already
kind of explained her flash costume a
little bit obviously they wanted her to
wear that so that you would think that
oh wow this is irises daughter in the
moments before they revealed it but you
noticed the key difference in her flash
symbol is that it's more of a small
badge that she wears on her chest just
like Barry does instead of being the
painted lightning bolt that excess has
in the comics the reason for that is
that the flash symbols even the old one
going back to season one have technology
embedded in them that helped them do
whatever it is they need to do to take
down that villain of the week I'm
bringing the heat right now
[Music]
irma threading babies a little something
I added for situations exactly like this
one
like during season 2 when Cisco built
the heater into the symbol so that it
could melt all of captain colds ice just
imagine in the future that probably
Cisco if he's still alive juiced up
irises costumes so that Nora could wear
with future technology so we'll see if
she has any special abilities in that
besides the communicator but for the
most part her abilities work just like
Barry's with the exception that she's
probably got a few things that Barry
hasn't tried before so like oh wow my
daughter's really awesome is the flash
look I never thought to do that before
so here's when we get to the Back to the
Future of it all one of the fun things
about making the season all about Nora
is is that she sort of the Marty McFly
in this Back to the Future situation so
what was the big ticking clock in Back
to the Future like the indicator of how
crap the future was going to be he was
the fading picture of Marty and his
brother and sister like if he messed the
future up they wouldn't exist anymore so
that was what the stakes were all about
I need to protect my future so that I
continue to exist so one of the fun
things about making the season all about
nora is is that as they tried to fix the
future their version of the picture our
Barry and Nora themselves like imagine
Nora messes something up in the past and
something about Barry changes in the
future but then later in the season they
make you really care about Nora like
Barry wants to save his daughter but
they do something that changes the
future and she is the one that
disappears so Barry has to fight to get
his daughter back so that's what the
stakes are all about really awesome news
is that we got all the trailers coming
in the next couple of days
first big panel that's happening is
Thursday that's Young Justice season 3
so whatever they drop online I will
totally do a video for it I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post that too
click here to learn about sinister six
in the next big spider-man film and
click here for my Aquaman trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]